you know a lot of movies try to be tense
I mean this is and it holds you for the
whole it really does it takes place in
real time the two hours that this this
operation takes to to be completed is
exactly the sort of the two hours of the
movie so it's a kind of forensic
examination of all the decisions that
have to go into something yes
extraordinary I didn't know about this I
think the majority of the audience won't
understand in in a strike like this
specifically like this this is exactly
what would happen in terms of the chain
of command going all the way up to the
Prime Minister if necessary and nobody
as you see in the movie quite wanting to
make a decision it's a great class of
Americans and British actors and we must
mention at the lake great Alan Rickman
who was it perfect yes fantastic we got
the phone it's a brilliant fitting final
performance it is I think it's a movie
you would be very proud of in the sense
that he would appreciate what the film
was about and the way in which it it
tells its story it doesn't take sides
incidentally that makes me moral
decisions it just throws up the moral
questions but but what I love about the
film is is it's Alan as I knew Alan you
know I mean he was a brilliant character
actor and we see him in Harry Potter and
die hard playing these extraordinary
characters that is Alan as he really is
you know funny a Bain intelligent very
human and so it's really great to see
him up there there is action in this
film even though you know you're in that
room but you have done kind of big
actually you did the you know the red
rope yes and now I hear I don't of
history that you are gunning to be in a
big action franchise yes fast and
furious I would love to be in Fast and
Furious no no of course this incredible
fun to do that movies aren't they I mean
they're they're like just you don't act
see you
how are interested yeah it's amazingly
set all these things and things explode
all around you and oh it's unbelievable
fun and that we cars like that would be
my dream come true
some selling sort of toiletry products
as a rep up and down the country but you
never gave up the dream of being a pop
star but that you're in the new one
you're in the new store well hardly I
mean I'm my voice is in it for a second
I recorded a little line in it